حرر زكاري مجموعة من زكري المفرج عنهم GPS
والمتقاعد أه القائد الأعلى لحلف شمال الأطلسي
الجنرال ويسلي كلارك جنرال
كلارك ما هو رد فعلك على هذه
الضربات الجديدة حسنًا، أنا سعيد لأننا
تابعنا ذلك، أعتقد أننا مازلنا نقوم بـ
BDA أم علينا ذلك  قم بعمل أفضل في
الاستهداف والطريقة التي تفعل بها ذلك هي
الضرب، ووضع العينين والأذنين مرة أخرى على
المنطقة، ومشاهدة رد الفعل أه،
والنظر إليه بعناية، وبناء الحزمة المستهدفة الخاصة بك
ولكن في كل حالة أه أتمنى ذلك
سنحاول تحقيق
هيمنة التصعيد على القلنسوات إذا أطلقوا
صاروخًا واحدًا، فسنقضي على ثلاثة أهداف إذا
أطلقوا ثلاثة صواريخ، فسنقضي على ستة
أهداف، وبعبارة أخرى، نحاول
الابتعاد عن الضربة القاضية، وفي النهاية إذا
لم نتمكن من أخذها  من الأصول التي
يستخدمونها لضرب هذه السفن، علينا أن نذهب
للعثور على الأصول التي تقدر قيمتها بدرجة أكبر والتي تم
تحريرها بدرجة أكبر، ما الذي فعلته هذه الضربات
الليلة الماضية، وفي هذه الجولة الأخيرة،
ما رأيك في ذلك يعني بالنسبة
لآفاق  صراع أوسع في
المنطقة أه بالتأكيد يزيد من
الاحتمالات وكان صحيحا دائما
أن هذا صراع
يتحول دائما إلى شيء أكبر
والسبب أه إيران لديها العديد من الحلفاء
ومعظم حلفائها مثل الهويس
هؤلاء  المقاتلون بالوكالة حزب الله أه حويس حماس
طبعا أه وما
فعله الحوثيون أنهم وجدوا طريقة
لإيقاع التكلفة عليك كما تعلمون العمل
كالمعتاد لذلك على الولايات المتحدة أن
ترد وعليها أن تحاول تحقيق
هيمنة التصعيد أه كما  كان ويست كلارك
يقول ولكن عليه أيضًا أن يحاول عدم
السماح لهذا بالانتشار خارج نطاق السيطرة
وهذا توازن دقيق جدًا وهو
يحاول إعادة إنشاء الردع أه وفي
نفس الوقت لا يؤدي في حد ذاته إلى
توسيع الحرب أه لست
متأكدًا  هذا هناك الكثير من الخطر هنا
لأن الولايات المتحدة يمكن أن
تنجر إلى الشيء الذي
كانت واشنطن تطلب من المملكة العربية السعودية توخي
الحذر منه وهو أنه إذا قمت بسحب
نفسك إلى أه، فأنت تعرف حربًا أهلية يمنية
تقف إلى جانب جانب واحد يهاجم هس
أه  يمكن أن يستمر ذلك لفترة طويلة،
لذلك هناك هذا الخطر، ومن ناحية
أخرى، يجب عليك التأكد من
أن الشحن يمكن أن يمر عبر
الخليج الفارسي، وهذا هو شريان الحياة لجزء
كبير من العالم، وهذا هو المكان الذي
يتدفق إليه النفط.  الكثير من الأماكن في جميع أنحاء
العالم